this is a far more common scenario in a
bag there are four green three blue and
five red disks okay so how many disks
are there in total four three five beds
12 disks right so the silly way of doing
this would be say well there's 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 11 12 options right but
because so many of them are the same and
we're gonna count for their different
weights with these numbers here I only
really have three alternatives right
just a three represented by the three
colors let's start drawing that out is
it red green blue so we don't yes
blue okay so we've got our start up
scenario right you're gonna work out the
sample space which we already did which
is 12 in this scenario
so we've got how many red how many red
do we have 512 for green so 4 out of 12
which is equal to so faster group right
okay now this this scenario has two
different halves okay and they would
have two different diagrams if we needed
to draw it but as you'll see shortly we
don't need to two disks are drawn at
random and the first disk is not
replaced before the second disk is drawn
right so this important key phrase we
might put this over the top without
replacement rather than Kia they're
explicitly just giving you the numbers
from one stage one game to it to the
next this is exactly how they changed
well without replacement again tells you
that that probably is our dynamic you
write whatever happens here whatever I
draw out first is going to affect what
happens next
okay so again for each case I've got my
three authors
by the way if you're like me and
especially when you're doing in your
book not when you have like enormous
meters of space to draw your diagram if
you like me and you sort of do this like
here's my three and then you start to
draw and you're like oh no I've run out
of space and sort of you know things go
a bit wonky and crap together
what you can think about is the fact
that you know right from the beginning
how many alternatives there will be out
here at the end you know what the total
sample space would be how can you work
it out what why is it in this case why
is it that there are 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
alternatives at the end where is that 9
come from and the answer is it comes
from 3 times 3 right 3 times 3 if for
instance on the second go you know
you've lost one of the alternatives
right so it was 3 times 2 maybe you were
peeing from a different bag which only
has the two different colors right then
you're gonna have 3 here and each one of
those 3 branches will have to suit your
3 times - there'll be six alternatives
right if you were rolling a die and then
you were flipping a coin there'd be six
times - there be 12 so you can actually
write this side first and then go
backwards and then you know you won't
end up in this situation where
everything gets transferred
anyway might think let's have a look at
the probabilities now the first thing I
would do is I would say if there's no
replacement then I already know that
every single one of these nine branches
the sample space will be the same namely
it's a doff 11 there are 11 left
okay I'll do this all first I can get
out of the way and now I can just think
about the counting brother okay so I
picked the red one I picked the red one
so this side of it five and now there
will be four of them left right so this
will be four of her 11th
how many greens are the left still the
same number I started with four and how
did blues say in deal okay
coming into here I've picked green so
the number of Reds has not changes still
five the number of Reds from migraines
has dropped down from four to three and
there are still three blues and then
final scenario original number of red
still their original number of green
still there and I'm missing one okay now
because they're armed alternatives here
I might not go through and draw
everything have a look at the question
and see what they're looking for part
one find the property to join to read
discs it easy it's right there at the
top isn't it probability of to read
discs okay
by the way like I said before just like
you don't want to say P equals this and
then P equals this and then P equals
this because what are all of these there
are all different things but you don't
know what they are in the same way if
you've gone to the effort to draw a
diagram your mind as well use that for
your scaffold for where your answers are
gonna be don't just put this off at some
random spot put it where it belongs up
there and then everything will be
orderly and you won't miss out anything
so again using the plant rule we're
gonna say 5 over 12 4 times 1132 I think
and of course it's sort of standard for
me to simplify that what's the I mean I
suppose we should have said 5 beginning
that's a better way into it happy cool
what's the next thing I ask one red and
one blue one red and one blue okay
now the good thing about this this
diagram is it clearly shows you there
are different ways of getting one red
and one blue because that doesn't tell
you anything about order right so here's
one here the probability of the red
first and then the other ones all the
way down here probably that you're
getting the blue one first okay
so again go through the branches five
three and you've got okay
now what's interesting is have a look
even though we got at different ways
what's happening same probability right
clearly it's the same probability
because you're always going to be over
12 and then over 11 right you're gonna
pick one from the Reds and one through
the blues and there's going to be the
same number in both scenarios right so
actually you can add these up or you can
just double one of them so now when I
double of five over 22 happy with that
cool you get going they start to get
trickier right but just be mindful
remember we learnt three basic rules
that put everything together you have
the park rule like okay you follow along
the branches you got the addition rule
like take three different scenarios
which you cannot happen simultaneously
addemup what was the third and last one
it's the condiment and it's it's really
powerful it will save you lots of time
okay if you know to look for it which
means you should always look for it
example look at the last one two
differently colored discs two
differently colored discs now I will
write out the sample space just so you
can see he's red green right here is
green red green green blue green and
blue tell me how many ways are there how
many four combinations are there that
will give me two different colored discs
and ants
there are six one two three four oh I've
missed what this one
starting here one two three four five
six okay
so usually a putt Rock and in ditional
of course I could just add up all six of
those ah is this my way of course you
can use the compliment right because the
compliment of those six is is these
three these three red red green green
blue okay which of course if you went
through the whole question you've
already worked out in the previous part
right so you work out that probability
and then the probability I would write
it like this
the probability of different colors
right is equal to the probability it's
the complement of them being the same
right this is the way that I would write
it so it's 1 minus the probability of
them being the same and you can work out
what that is much faster okay much
faster by the way doctorates keep that
don't skip that that's a really
important logical step as a marker I am
looking at the fractions the fractions
only tell me so much you can see that
they are often the same even from
different points of view okay but this
this I can clearly see what's going on
in your head right so that's really
valuable right and also save you a lot
of time when you're if you go back and
you're checking you know it's not just
me knowing what was going on your head
it's you knowing what was going on your
head half an hour ago you're like I
can't remember
they just fractions that don't mean
anything to me